Ну ви що робите взагалі Нащо це робити а
далі Ми вийдемо і скажемо А ви знаєте в
нас проблеми Сполучених Штатах ай-яйяйяй
як виходить А ви знаєте в нас проблеми в
Євросоюзі ай-яй-яй Які Так це ж ганьба
якась далі буде виходити президент і
казати яні тряпка Нащо це все Чому ви
просто нехтуєте тими людьми кого ми же
просимо ну це одно вийде як людина і
кажете допоможіть мені вам говорять
добре Ми допоможемо Але ми хочемо бачити
як ти витрачаєш ці кошти а ти кажеш Да
пошли ви да це що ж взагалі таке друзі
Схаменіться не робіть цього не
протягуйте просто щоб зробити головою
рахункової палати цю піщанську наближену
до родини зеленських на її сестру
оформлене Вілла роди Нащо це все робити
буде чергова ганьба
зупиниться